stock fotos jeder von euch sollte sie
kennen und jeder von euch hat
wahrscheinlich schon mal eine werbung
gesehen in denen stock fotos benutzt
werden
das macht so ziemlich jede firma egal ob
groß oder klein egal wo auf der welt ich
dann da mal ein bisschen genauer darüber
nachgedacht habe ist in mir die frage
aufkommen ob es wohl möglich wäre es
doch fotos nach zu machen werbung zu
faken die in leiden zu hängen ohne dass
die mitarbeiter merken dass die werbung
gar nicht von ihnen ist und da ist
natürlich komplett langweilig wäre
einfach nur irgendwo stumpf werbung
aufzuhängen habe ich mich für die
plakate noch etwas besonderes überlegt
viel spaß mit wie schwer ist es werbung
zu wecken ohne dass mitarbeiter ist
merken
[Musik]
stock fotos sehen eigentlich immer
gleich es ist ein helles design die
leute lachen schauen vielleicht aufs
handy und das ist irgendwie eine gruppe
von freunden oder scheint zumindest so
als allererstes benötigen wir also die
freundesgruppe und genau deswegen machen
uns jetzt auf dem weg zu max und jakob
den beiden besten männern die sich auf
diesem stock foto als sehr gute models
machen werden
wir brauchen zwei freunde sei gut
aussehende freunde ja fakt sei leider
sind sie irgendwo hängen bleiben
eigentlich hatte ich vor relativ ernste
bilder zu machen also auf ernst stock
bilder zu machen jetzt ist es doch in
ein relativ spaßiges ding ausgeartet ich
glaube aber das könnte die sache noch
ein bisschen interessanter machen jetzt
geht's ab nach hause wir bearbeiten die
bilder und vielleicht können wir noch
ein bisschen was dran rum tricksen wie
es jetzt zufällig ein mcus wir gehen
jetzt direkt beim auskundschaften wo wir
das plakat gleich aufhängen könnte also
lasst uns
denn als
[Musik]
theoretisch können wir das hier überall
nicht so sehen die fotos aus die dabei
umgekommen
die größten chancen mal ich mir bei
fastfood ketten aus deswegen haben wir
uns für subway starbucks und mcdonald's
entschieden und als allerletztes noch
die kölner verkehrs-betriebe weil es
gibt einfach viele bahnhöfe wo wir die
sachen einfach aufhängen kann ja jetzt
sind halt viele fotos dabei rumgekommen
die nicht nach typischen stock fotos
aussehen sondern einfach komplett nimmt
und ich halte das jetzt einfach für die
fünf die auf also zwei der werbung
werden komplett normal aussehen so als
könnten das einfach wirklich werbung
sein und bei zwei der plakate scheiße
einfach komplett rein und machen die
offensichtlich falsch oder komisch
bearbeitet sieht das kvb plakat jetzt so
aus also davon überzeugt dass das
einfach so wirklich eine kampagne sein
könnte und irgendwo im bahnhof hängen
könnte da macht man eigentlich wenig
gedanken dass es abgenommen
genauso weiß aktuell wir haben uns an
einer bestehenden werbung orientiert und
dieses 1000 punkte denkt einfach
wirklich genauso übernommen und das
sieht wirklich so aus als wäre es eine
richtige subway werbung bei starbucks
sieht das schon anders aus zum einen
hatten wir kein starbucks becher beim zu
tun also habe ich einfach an dem
objektiv getrunken
in photoshop dann das objektiv durch den
sehr schlecht editierten becher
ausgewechselt und dabei auch nicht auf
sachen geachtet wie dass die flüssigkeit
eigentlich raus laufen müsste sondern
wir lassen das einfach so außerdem haben
wir den werbeslogan noches coffee punkt
punkt punkt just coffee unten in der
ecke dann noch ein lob zum text also das
einfach ein platzhalter text der von
designern genutzt wird und das vierte
und letzte ist dass mcdonald's plakat
also als aller erstes mal das
ausgangsbild dann haben wir in den
comics haben uns einfach mcdonald's
verbindet darüber geschrieben also
comics als hat wirklich rein gar nichts
mit mcdonald's schriften oder
schriftarten zu tun und wir haben einen
qr-code hinzu dieser qr-code link zu
einem video von max dass sich nennt
dieses klo spritzpistole das habe ich
einfach gemacht weil sie eine unserer
freundesgruppe so ein running gag
geworden ist dass dieses video mit
diesem namen so viele views bekommen
habe damit sehr gut gewappnet für die
idee und wir haben einen vernünftigen
ausgleich aus werbung die wirklich so
sein könnte und werbung die einfach
kompletter quatsch ist es ist soweit
wir haben alle vier jetzt klappen
den werden wir starten bei max manchmal
glück
[Musik]
ok freunde mussten die mcus missionen
abbrechen aber viel zu viel los und da
saß mal überall kunden rum und die
mitarbeiter konnten das auch perfekt
sind also gehen jetzt als allererstes
auf die kvb werbung und dafür haben wir
uns den ranglisten bahnhof in ganz köln
ausgesucht riesen platz gegen die machen
die kastration mit ihr eingehen können
und das direkt an geben wir richtig
aufgeregt oder kannst die kvb glücklich
mit dem perfekten werbegesicht
muriel werbung zu
eigentlich kann nichts passieren sie
bekommen konturlose werbung von uns wenn
jetzt hier alles die luft rein ist damit
das jüngste mit vornamen
[Musik]
war alles easy kaum hier unten an den
auch nicht so viele leute vorbei und
dort befinden sich drei lieblings
werbegesichter bin so fucking gespannt
als ob das morgen noch da hängen wird
oder uns weg sein wird ob die leute das
checken weil diese werbung sieht halt
wirklich einhundertprozentig hochwertig
sie ist gut gemacht sie weist auf die
kvb erkennen genau das wofür die kvb in
letzter zeit werbung gemacht hat also
eigentlich ist passt die same-store
option
haben sie
es bietet nämlich in die partie
[Musik]
ich melde mich ganz kurz aus der zukunft
und aus dem schnitt das video war jetzt
echt eine menge arbeit viel mehr als ich
gedacht habe und wir haben echt geld
reingesteckt also wenn du mich support
wollte las dem video und leichter und
kommentiert was euch am besten gefallen
hat einem video
vielen dank dann sind wir die top
werbegesichter 2020 und salat hat mich
mal jemand es hat sich keiner eine
sekunde dafür interessiert das ist
nämlich das ding man macht sich dabei
immer so ein bisschen gedanken aber es
interessiert halt wirklich kein
[Musik]
werbegesichter von mcdonald's starbucks
kaffee jetzt gleich viel geld machst du
eigentlich mit dem ganzen körper
andere leute lassen sich dafür bezahlen
wer übergewicht wegen mit kampagne zu
sein
max jacob und nichts entscheiden uns
einfach für vier unternehmen kostenlos
werbung zu machen und die sachen auch
noch selber aufzuhängen
irgendwas machen wir falsch ist dort
alles perfekt funktioniert als letzte
station subway wenn es weiter so läuft
[Musik]
der immer besser
so sind mittlerweile mehrere tage
vergangen um genau zu sein drei und ich
mache mich jetzt auf dem weg zum
starbucks und vw um zu sehen ob die
anzeigen dort machen
in der zwischenzeit weich und in berlin
wenn jetzt wieder zurück in köln und
jetzt ist der zeitpunkt gekommen wo wir
die auflösung haben voller elan und
freude habe ich mich auf dem weg zu
starbucks begeben um zu sehen dass da
was hat es anscheinend gemerkt und unser
plakat runter genommen
das ist sehr sehr ärgerlich aber wir
haben ja noch diverse andere plakate
aufgehangen also ist es überhaupt kein
problem dachte ich zumindest machen uns
jetzt auf den weg
unten in die haltestelle um zu sehen ob
das kvb dennoch hängt der moment der
wahrheit tag das einzige was wir noch
finden ist ein pater fix rest scheiße
das ist sehr sehr ärgerlich ich hatte
mir bei den kvb dingen die größten
chancen erhofft das bedeutet jetzt noch
mcdonalds und subway mal sehen sichtlich
niedergeschlagen habe ich mich also auf
dem weg zur rektorin gemacht nur um zu
sehen dass im endeffekt das wackligen
plakate einfach nur älter ist das geil
tonnen sind leider noch nicht ganz film
weil die leute vor sitzen aber ich
probiere es jetzt irgendwie zu machen
[Gelächter]
das direkt nach vorne die kasse ist und
dieses will also riesenerfolg wenn wir
irgendwann mal in köln unterwegs sein
sollte ich habe das natürlich hängen
lassen also mcdonald's rudolfplatz guckt
euch das plakat an direkt wenn er
reinkommt
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich sagen ist meine stimmung
auch wieder viel viel besser und wir
hoffen dass jetzt im subway das auch
noch hängt dann hätten wir 50 prozent
also eine 50 prozentige trefferquote
dass die unternehmen das nicht merken
konnte
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so das war echt ein voller erfolg also
in zwei der unternehmen ist das plakat
hängen geblieben das wollte mich sehr
und ihr könnt die plakate nach wie vor
an sehen also ich schätze dass sie immer
noch hängen das video echt eine menge
arbeit also lasst dem video und leid da
und kommentiert und abonniert damit ihr
nichts mehr verpasst vielen dank fürs zu
sehen wir sehen uns am mittwoch